ي الله كنا قبل قليل عند منزل
استهدف استهدف في هذا في في مكان قريب من
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه عندما سمعنا صوت
انفجار شديد على مقربه من المكان على عجل
وصلنا لنشاهد لنصل قبل ان تصل جيران هذا
المنزل وكما
تشاهدون بدا
الاطفال
تنتشل من المكان ويبدو انه احد المنازل
التي
استهدفت كما
تشاهدون
حمدان هذا هو منزل استهدف بواحده من
الغارات
الاسرائيليه
المدمره كما تشاهدون اله
مشاهد مروعه هذا الطفل الثاني
الذي
رايناه
ينتشل لكن من الواضح ان التضاريس في هذه
المنطقه تضاريس
صعبه ولذلك تضاريس صعبه
ولذلك ربما
هناك صعوبه
كبيره عن بعد عن بعد عن عن بعد عن عن
البعد عن بعد عن بعد عن بعد اذا في داخل
هذه السياره
اناس
اناس استشهدوا الانفجار اخر قريب من
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه كما تشاهدون
المواطنون الفلسطينيون هم من ياتون الى
المكان يحاولون انتشال ما يمكن انتشاله
كما
تشاهدون ولكن بالتاكيد حتى الان سيارات
الاسعاف لم تصل الى هذا المكان بالتاكيد
اعتبار اننا تواجدنا صدفه في
هذا
المكان
و حتى الان لم تصل سيارات الدفاع المدني
ولا سيارات الاسعاف طلعونا الناس بعجبه
تحت الرن ك هذول اولاد مرمي على الارض ولا
كيف واحد ثاني عندهه انتشال
جديد لبعض
الجثامين في هذه
المنطقه التي
تغطيها الركام وايضا رائحه
البارود وروائح صعبه جدا في هذه
المنطقه كما
تشاهدون هنا ماساه حقيقيه كانه كان هذا
المكان تحول الى خندق للموت كما تشاهدون
باعتباره يقع بين ثلاثه منازل تم تدميرها
بفعل القصف
الاسرائيلي وشبان جيران هذه
المنازل
يحاولون الوصول جاهدين وهم
تباعا
يحاولون
المصابين او
الشهداء من هذه
المنطقه وواضح
ان درج هذا المنزل
متهالك واجزاء منه تتساقط
تباعا في محاوله لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
يحاولون انتشال من كانوا بداخل
هذه
البنايه
الان فرق كثيره للانقاذ اينما تولي
وجهك
تجد
اناس يحاولون انتشال من
يجدونه على سطح
هذه الحجاره
والركام من اجل اجلائهم تمهيدا لوصول
سيارات الاسعاف الان نحو اربع سيارات
اسعاف وصلت بالفعل الى المكان والشبان
يحاولون نقل هذه
الجثامين والجرحى نحن لا نعرف ما اذا
كانوا شهداء على وجه الدقه ام لا ولكن
بالتاكيد معظم من رايناهم يخرجون من هذا
المكان هم من النساء والاطفال حسب ما
شاهدنا وشاهدت معنا من خلال عدسه الكاميرا
وهذه يتوجب القول بان هذا المربع هو واحد
من المربعات التي اعلن عنها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
كمربين في منطقه غرب خانيونس
ولذلك ربما هذه المنازل تعج بالنازحين اسر
باكملها موجوده في هذه اتت بما فيها ليله
امس اتوا الى هذه المنازل في محاوله للبحث
عن الامن والامان ولكن كما تشاهدون جميع
من كان بداخل هذه المنازل تحولوا الى ما
بين شهيد وجريح في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي كما تشاهدون الان الحديث يدور عن
عشرات ربما اكثر من عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى هم من كانوا يتواجدون داخل
هذا هذه المنازل الثلاثه بالاضافه الى
المنازل
المجاوره ولكن
منها يعني المشهد صعب جدا ومروع جدا وكما
تشاهدون الناس يحاولون بمجهوداتهم الشخصيه
الفرديه ازاله بعض الركام بعض الحطام بعض
الواح الصفيح من مكان يعتقدون انه يتواجد
تحت هذا الركام اناس من سكان هذه المنازل
ولذلك يركزون هذه الجهود
بجاه هذه المنطقه كما
تلاحظون
لاخلاء
بعض
ال مواطنين الفلسطينيين سواء كانوا
شهداء او كانوا جرحى يطلبون بعض الاغطيه
والفرشات وهذا يعني انهم تمكنوا من ايجاد
جثامين اخرى ربما تكون لنساء باعتبار ان
معظم بداخل هذه المنازل كما قيل لنا من
شهود العيان هم من النساء
والاطفال وائل الدحدوح الجزيره خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه